blutüberströmt schleppt sich bernd b im
juli mit letzter kraft in seine
werkstatt in breckerfeld bei hagen er
kann doch die bürotüre verriegeln und
den notruf wählen hilfe ich wurde gerade
überfallen aber der hilferuf kommt zu
spät in seiner autowerkstatt bricht der
mann zusammen einsatzkräfte können sein
leben nicht mehr retten bernd b wird mit
23 messerstichen ermordet der
mutmaßliche täter sein praktikant
russland k
bundesweit hatte die polizei nach ihm
gefahndet
russland k 20 jahre alt der am 6 juli in
breckerfeld bei hagen den
werkstattbesitzer bernd b im streit
erstochen haben soll rund vier wochen
später ging der deutsch kasache der
polizei in dülmen ins netz festnahme
nach bisherigen erkenntnissen hatte
russland am tag zuvor in der werkstatt
gearbeitet er stellte sich offenbar
nicht besonders gut an geriet laut
anderen mitarbeitern mit dem chef in
streit der ersetzte ihn vor die tür zu
später stunde kehrte russland kam
offenbar zurück und griff bernd b an als
die retter am einsatzort eintrafen war
der blutüberströmte mann bereits tot
sein körper wies 23 stich und
schnittverletzungen auf traurig aber
wahr gegen den mutmaßlichen täter hatte
das amtsgericht iserlohn nur 14 tage
zuvor ein strafverfahren wegen schwerer
körperverletzung eingestellt heute wird
sich russland kam vor der
jugendstrafkammer des landgerichts hagen
wegen totschlags verantworten müssen
und bild reporter alex ahlerstedt
begleitet diesen prozess für uns kurz
vor verhandlungsbeginn konnte er noch
mal mit dem gerichtssprecher sprechen
wir befinden uns im schwurgerichtssaal
am landgericht hagen und in wenigen
minuten beginnt der prozess russland
klavier durch diese tür im hintergrund
gleich von der justiz meisterei in den
saal geführt neben mir steht jetzt
gerichtssprecher bernhard kouchner herr
kugler es gibt neue
sicherheitsvorkehrungen hier am
landgericht hagen was gibt es für eine
anordnung der angeklagte wird besonders
gefesselt wenn er vorgeführt wird
handfesseln fußfesseln der hintergrund
ist dass er zuletzt in der
untersuchungshaft sich auffällig gezeigt
haben soll und dann möchte man jetzt für
die haupthandlung kein risiko eingehen
russland ist 20 jahre alt
die staatsanwaltschaft hagen hat
angeklagt wegen totschlag das gericht
hat aber auch gesagt es könnte eventuell
mord in frage kommt warum totschlag ist
ja erstmal jede vorsätzliche tötung
eines menschen das ist das was angeklagt
ist und zu einem mord wird eine solche
vorsätzliche tötung mit besonders
erschwerende umstände dazu kommen und da
hat das gericht nach einer ersten
einschätzung der der akten jetzt den
hinweis erteilt und hat gesagt wir
müssen im verfahren auch prüfen ob es
nicht vielleicht mord ist weil hier als
motiv der tatwaffe in betracht kommt und
wenn das einzige motiv für die tat rache
war dann kann man das als sonstige
niedere beweggründe einstufen und das
wäre dann ein mord herzlichen dank herr
pocher ja und der täter hat gegenüber
seinem anwalt gesagt er wird sich im
prozess erstmal nicht äußern
insgesamt sind rund 80 zeugen und vier
sachverständige eingeladen an neuen
termin soll das soll dieser prozess
stattfinden und mit mitte februar soll
dann eventuell ein urteil fallen ich
habe auch mit der familie gesprochen bzw
mit der opferanwältin die witwe ist als
nebenklägerin hier im prozess und die
familie ist immer noch am boden zerstört
und fühlt sich auch nicht in der lage
den mörder gegenüberzustehen